بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسول رسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في
رياضه في كتاب العلم في باب فضل العلم
تعلما وتعليما لله تعالى
وعن ابي موسى اي ابي موسى الاشعري
رضي الله عنه قال قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم و الاشعري نسبه الى بني اشعر
واشعر من اجداد عظماء اليمن
ف
متى وجد الاشعري
فاصل هذه القبيله
من اليمن
وقد ابتعث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ابا
موسى الاشعري الى اليمن مع معاذ بن جبل
داعيا الى الله
و
جامعا للزكاه ومبلغا عن رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
و
الاشعريون لهم
بشكل خاص
منزله رفيعه
في الاسلام
اهل اليمن بشكل عام والاشعريون بشكل خاص
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول مدحا لاهل
اليمن
بارك الله لنا في شامنا وفي يمننا واعادها
ثلاثا
وقال صلى الله عليه وسلم كما في الصحيح
الايمان يمان والحكمه يمانيه
وقال في الاشعريين
انهم اذا ارملوا في السير
جمعوا ما كان معهم من زاد واقتسموه بينهم
على السويه فهم مني وانا منهم صلى الله
عليه
الاشعري ابو مالك الاشعري ابو موسى
الاشعري
اشعر يمنر
سهران
يمن
الاشعريين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ايمان
يمني
صلى الله عليه وسلمشعريين
ابو موسى الاشعري والسنت
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اليمن
الله
معاذ بن جبل
ابو موسى الاشعري رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
استمعوا الى هذا الحديث لا يصلح لمؤمن
الا يكون من احد هذين النوعين
الذين سيذكرهما النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
هو يذكر ثلاثه
ثلاث انواع
الرجال
فاثنان يحث المؤمن ان يكون من احدهما ان
لم يكن من كليهما واما الثالث فهو المذموم
يقول ما مثل ما بعثني الله به من الهدى
والعلم علم الهدى بمعنى الاعمال الصالحه
والعلم بمعنى الايمانيات والنبوات
والاشياء التي ا يعتقدها الانسان يقول مثل
ما بعثني الله به من الهدى والعلم كمثل
غيث الغيث المطر الشديد اصاب ارضا
فكانت منها اي من هذه الارض طائفه طيبه
قبلت الماء فانبتت الكلا والعشب الكثير
هذا النوع الاول وكان منها اجادب اجاذب
يعني امكنه
هي ليست خصبه للزرع لكنها تمسك الماء لا
تشرب الميه تبقي الماء على وجهها ومنها
البحور والعيون وما شابه ذلك والانهار هذه
اجاذب يقول وكان منها اجادب امسكت الماء
فنفع الله بها الناس فشربوا منها وسقوا
وزرعوا
صلى الله عليه وسلمر
always mention
when
‏in
canalysical
and can understical
which is theation
andر that comes from above and so the
propetai
he mentions the that comes which
‏Now what this
in
the
qu upon
it any impuries and nourishes anyed
[Silence]
‏only
understand if not understand it mayor
but will not bring forth the fr except
of that which it has underst this is a
very important analy
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران سوره الرعد سوره الرعد
الرعد
‏tyes
that forth different tyes of fr and
vegetation
even though all of the land is nourished
by the
same com down and different nation
different civilations different people
different individuals and communities
they bring forth very different fruits
all coming from what from the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مثل ما بعثني الله من الهدى والنور
الله
and
that came down upon a of land one of
that land ‏was very pure and was very
was very pure and was very fertile.
‏And so when the rain came down, it took
the rain in and gave and gave forth
vegetation. ‏different things to come
out we all stand here
and all thele
in the way different and fr
here the fr of what we of the if we were
pay atttion is going to be slightly
different but all of benit to humanity
right and ‏So he says one type of land
it took the water in and it brought
forth vegetation. ‏The second type was
not fertile.
However, it was strong and pure and so
it h the water
so that others could come and drink from
it. So humans and animals, they all come
to these rivers, to these lakes, to
these ponds, to these bodies of water,
and they drink right. ‏But there are
those who understand they memoriz and
understand
they bring forth what we know as
how to impement the quران and then we
have others who are not strongest in
that but they are trustwthy and they
hold the water for others to benefit
from but then there's a third type so
now we have a responsibility to at least
be one of these two types
[Silence]
واصاب طائفه منها انما هي قيعان لا تمسك
ماء ولا تنبت كلاء فذلك مثل من فقها في
دين الله فقها فقه كلاهما صحيح يعني فهم
في دين الله ونفعه ما بعثني الله به فعلم
وعلمه
ومثل من لم يرفع بذلك راسا ولم يقبل هدى
الله الذي ارسلت به متفق
‏ty
this comes down is noter
is not trwthy it does not hold the water
hit it sucks the water in that's it
doesn't any fruits and it doesn't hold
the water for anyone else it just sucks
the water in
and so he says that is differ
الله
mention
howر
themi
‏go tole
that suff
over
whatever
it's put in the bottom so no matter how
much go in
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يفقهنا في
دينه وان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما
علمنا وان يزيدنا علما وتقا وان يسلل
سخيمه قلوبنا وان يسكل قلوبنا وافئدتنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يزكي نفوسنا وان
يؤتها تقواها انه وليها ومولاها والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
عبد ‏Ja.